[Musique]
mes amis l'ennemi est proche
l'ennemi est nombreux ces murmures se
font entendre ses passes se font chaque
jour plus lourd plus proche plus
distincts puisque yara greyjoy nous a
refusé son aide
nous allons devoir redoubler de
vigilance et de courage c'est ça la
dorsale dit vrai l'ennemi compte nous
envahir par les côtes
c'est pourquoi l'aide de leurs davos
nous sera précieuse nous devons bien
évidemment nous passer du soutien de
l'ordre ennemis et comme et daoud stark
robb stark l'ordre ig et jr mordaunt
avant nous nous devrons combattre
s'annonce longue et rude
c'est pourquoi la vigilance est de mise
vous allez prévenir brindami que nous
sommes en position
je vais y aller j'attends qu'elle est
quelconque tournant vous habite il
pourquoi les veaux vers le reste je sais
pas qui c'est voix pardonnez moi non
mais mâchant là le mec que je dois aller
chercher là son nom samedi quelque chose
mais je vois pas quelle tête
enfin il s'agit de l'oncle de catelyn
stark et des demeures je sais pas qui
c'est non plus je vous implore de
mesurer l'importance de la tâche qui
vous incombent
je vous rappelle que laure davos a
mobilisé ses troupes pour nous soutenir
c'est lequel il est blanc avec une barbe
à c'est le blanc avec une barbe d'accord
non mais on est tous blancs avec une
barbe non c'est pour ça l'est mais je me
rappelle un peu mieux tu à brienne serre
c'est cali si oui mais non elle
s'appelle d'amyris kelly 6 son titre
honorifique
le gros geek lord davos est un des plus
fidèles alliés de lord stanis stany
c'est le mec qui s'est tapé les mavs
qu'est la fumée qui sort de la chatte
maintenant mais si je vous jure il ya
genre trois ans il ya une meuf elle a
écarté les gens et tanus et le frère de
robert baratheon ah bah voilà lui je
sais qui c'est c'est le père du gamin
sans jambes qui traîne toujours avec le
gala comment il s'appelle mais qui dit
tout le temps au d'or au dehors
il répète son nom en fait non mais comme
me disait tout le temps aux doors ou
l'appeler comme ça c'est pas très
respectueux vers le mec est clairement
handicapé foot mais non et en plus je
suis là depuis le début mais dès que je
reconnais le nombre un gars il crevait
donc je laissais tomber quoi et en plus
ils s'appellent tous lord machin donc si
on faisait de la prénom nom serait plus
simple à retenir si vous ne vous estimez
pas la hauteur de votre mission je
trouverai quelqu'un pour vous remplacer
et vous serez emprisonné pour trahison
et bat j'allais partir justement donc
voilà
[Musique]
entendez moi sur le champ brendan kelly
j'apporte un message de la plus haute
importance l'ennemi après ceodore n'y a
aucune chance que vous soyez brenda te
lis qui me fait une blague pandore
qu'est le sinon le chemin peut-être pour
aller à la rencontre de brendan perry
rod sommes d'accord alors sinon je pense
à un truc à trois on dit le truc pour
voir si on pense la même chose
d'accord 1 2 3 10 aux morts j'avais dit
du par mois donc c'est ou au dehors du
coup j'adore aller
ouais je suis désolé angers j'ai pas
trop suivi bon bah si vous n'avez pas
suivi vous allez cliquer sur l'offre est
comme ça vous verrez ce qui s'est passé
est allé vous abonner à la chaîne
dévoile à nous staff golden goose h et
c'est ce qu'ils font les tutos c'est à
casser ou hockey lui ce sera peine de
mort c'est bon en fait je me rappelle
c'est bon je me suis abonnée c'est bon